-Guys, do you ever see a photo
in the news and go,
"Well, that headline
could be better
than what it is with the photo"?
Well, we're gonna
take care of that right now.
It's time
for "News and Improved."
Here we go.
-♪ News and Improved ♪
♪♪
-For example, check out
this first photo here.
The original headline was...
The headline
can definitely be improved
because if you only looked
at the photo,
the headline could have been...
[ Laughter ]
-Pumpkin head!
-Up next, this headline says...
Headline could have been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Oh, yes!"
Impossible.
This headline was...
Headline could've been...
He's like...
-[ Clicks tongue ]
-Next headline was...
Headline could've been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Slurps ]
-This next headline was...
Headline could've been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
The next headline was...
Headline could've been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Spits ]
Next headline was...
The headline could've been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
They look good.
This next headline was...
Headline could've been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally,
this headline was
Team Cuba competes
on artistic gymna--
[ Laughter ]
...artistic gymnastics.
-[ Laughs ]
Uh-oh.
-Headline could've been,
"Taco Bell's Volcano Taco
is back, baby!"
That's all the time
we have for "News and Improved."
Stick around. We'll be right
back with some amazing talents
from our viewers
around the world.
Come on back, everybody.